Once you've picked an object, you might want to drag it to a new position. Here
is a demo of dragging in action. It's a bit more involved, since you also have
to track and respond to mouse move and mouse self events. I'm not going to walk
through the codes since you can take a look yourself. The main question with
dragging in 3D space is how to constrain the third dimension? There are usually
two choices. One is to constrain the movement to be parallel to the screen
surface as seen in this demo. The other method is to limit movement of the
object to be on a world plane or other geometry in the scene. For example, if
you drag a handle on a face of a box to resize it, you limit interaction to be
along the face's normal direction. Beyond the various mouse and keyboard
combinations, double-click, Shift, and Ctrl keys, there are also different
forms of selection. In areas as diverse as real time strategy games, and
computer-aided design programs, you can select a whole set of objects by
drawing a rectangle around them on the screen. This sort of selection is done
by finding which objects are fully or partially inside what is essentially a
smaller frustum on the screen. Lasso selection let's you draw an arbitrary shape
on the screen for choosing a set of objects. Yippee ki-yay, these aren't built
into 3GS. I just wanted to point out some ways of doing selection. Keep in mind
that you don't have to make a selectable object a visible object. For example,
for positioning a directional light, you might put an invisible sphere in the
scene and make it selectable. Wherever the user clicks on the sphere determines
a point in space, which in turn, determines the direction the light comes from.
This is a far as we're going with selection and interaction. The rest of this
unit will be about animation, which is a huge topic.